en 1988 tenía 17 años como todo joven
quería cambiar el mundo junto con unos
amigos decidimos entrar a nuestro
colegio contamos con la ayuda del bueno
del bid luís el portero cuando un link
de acceso cogimos carteleras papel kraft
y en papel amos todo el colegio con la
letra de muere libre de crack imágenes
en que ocurrió al día siguiente 7 la
mañana estábamos en la oficina de
rectoría el padre miguel me imagino que
con ayuda del bueno louis nos había
citado dijimos nos expulsaron perdimos
nuestra oportunidad en el colegio pero
no algo pasó maravilloso el padre miguel
nos sentó a todos nos ubicó y los
muchachos
ustedes quieren cambiar el mundo hay dos
posibilidades la primera o empapelan
todos los colegios del planeta o la
segunda entienden que tienen que
prepararse y si se quieren preparar lo
mejor en la educación la educación para
la libertad fue la primera vez en mi
vida que entendí la educación como
utopía
la educación es el arma más importante
que ha creado la humanidad no hay otra
ni bélica ni tecnológica y social la
educación nos ha transformado nos brinda
la oportunidad de ser mejores nos da
capacidades nos potencia nos vuelve
realmente seres humanos sin embargo
durante los últimos años las últimas
décadas algo ha pasado se está secando
la estamos dejando morir es hora de
atenderla tradicionalmente los modelos
educativos en los que trabajamos
nosotros los profesores clasifican dan
notas excluyen se agregan algo está mal
en ese proceso empezamos a valorar
estamos certificados posicionamos el
ranking yo les pregunto tiene su sentido
yo yo trato de recordar la guerra
entregamos municiones damos armas con
qué objetivo con que la gente salga al
azar arrasar que no sé no sé no
encuentren sentido y es hora de que
repensemos realmente la educación hay
una experiencia triste que quiero
compartirles era profesor yo en el
caribe colombiano en un municipio
hermoso llama montelíbano córdoba era
proceder de constitución política
y luego como todos mis colegas pensamos
que la educación que damos nosotros le
da las armas a los chicos para
fortalecerse pero era un caso muy
especial ella quería ser enfermera toda
la vida desde que yo la conocí de ese
estilo y ya había querido el tema de la
salud llegó a un décimo era el año de su
graduación y el profesor de sociales es
decir yo decía que ya no estaba
preparada y aunque muchos me dijeron yo
dije no ella no va a aprobar el año
grave error años después nos volvemos a
encontrar y ya era jefe de enfermeras de
la cosa precisamente lo más duro ocurrió
me abrazó me saludó con fraternidad yo
no sabía qué hacer en el momento en que
ella me abraza y yo digo pero que hice
realmente le brinde un apoyo a su vida
esa decisión que tome sumó el tema de
educación es un tema que va más allá de
lo que nosotros hablamos pero el reto
más complejo en la actualidad la
educación es una de las empresas y
negocios más importantes en el globo se
calcula que cinco millones de dólares
cuesta la educación y vale la educación
en todo el planeta para ello para ese
valor tan inmenso franquicias
editoriales ranking expertos quieren
[ __ ] un poco del botín pero cuando yo
pienso de ellos estaremos hablando de
educación realmente vean normal los
colegios vean nuestras universidades
llenas de color diversión espacios
coloridos te venden productos
franquicias etcétera etcétera y eso está
muy bien pero sigo preguntándome en ese
colorido en esa electricidad de colores
que no nos acompaña a todos habrá
educación está el sentido de renovar
de renovarlos como sociedad es una
pregunta que tenemos todos que construir
y resolver
qué es lo maravilloso de la educación
quiero resumirse en dos conceptos el
primero la educación nuestra torna lo
que dije en los mitos antes la educación
nos dé la oportunidad de ser mejores a
la mujer al niño al anciano todos
podemos ser mejores con la educación
pero el segundo y casi poco lo
mencionamos es que la educación es un
gran paréntesis nosotros los adultos nos
acostumbramos a valer apellidos cuentas
bancarias colores de piel prestigio la
educación es un paréntesis entre
paréntesis no existe nada de eso que más
hermoso que un bonito ejercicio de
matemáticas una fórmula trigonométricas
un baile la obra literaria una historia
bien contada el descubrimiento del mundo
que es más hermoso que eso ustedes
recuerdan la trasnochada está haciendo
un ejercicio matemáticas ahí no habían
apellido ni color ni sabor quedamos
nosotros éramos nosotros realmente
y qué debemos hacer mi planteamiento es
que tenemos que llegar a la utopía
recuperar el espacio del soñar en la
educación como decía del [ __ ] caldeando
el escritor uruguayo que es la autovía
es esa meta
a veces inalcanzable tú ves que se mueve
y se mueve es difícil llegar pero te
obliga una cosa te obliga a caminar y yo
creo que caminemos en conjunto en pos de
la educación
considero que la educación para la
autonomía tiene cuatro principios
básicos el primero debe servir para auto
confrontarlos debe permitir que cuando
miremos el espejo ese que está al frente
ella que está al frente no se sienta un
extraño que sea capaz de identificarse
su belleza sus fortalezas sus
debilidades
la forma en que ama la forma en que a
veces odia todo esto de ser posibilidad
en la educación la auto confrontación
permitirá que uno mismo se reconozca
pero también quiere conozcamos a los
demás es un arma de paz si tú entiendes
que la otra persona hace su mejor
esfuerzo y lo ves en ti no podemos
combatir entre nosotros
el segundo elemento el segundo pilar de
esta educación para la utopía es
queremos cambiar una palabra que está
muy maltratada de la palabra éxito
siempre nos imaginamos el prestigio la
opulencia el mostrar pero recuerden algo
el éxito de una persona significa el
fracaso de otro
y si eso está vivo en nuestras palabras
en nuestra mente y nuestra acción ese no
puede ser el modelo de éxito no nos
podemos mala gloria por carros por joyas
por cuentas bancarias porque nos
vanagloriamos de lo importante lapan
también nos enseñó algo del pan y me nos
enseñó que el éxito realmente tiene que
ver más con ese médico con esa
enfermedad con ese profesor que
sostuvieron el mundo ética correctamente
valoremos esa forma de entender el éxito
es el momento
el tercer pilar es el complemento la
educación nos abre la posibilidad de
complementar los la educación para la
utopía no es más que una suma de
complementos y quiero que partamos del
primer complemento el más importante el
trascendente complemento ser humano
naturaleza desde que se mercantiliza el
mundo la hemos castigado la utilizamos
la explotamos la calentamos ya es
momento decir no más tenemos que
valorarla y sentidos parte arte y
esencia en natural
pero no se dijo complemento está el
complemento generacional hoy estoy
hablando acá ante muchos jóvenes jóvenes
niños personas mayores tenemos que
unirnos en el esfuerzo de recuperar la
esencia cuál es la esencia educativa
renovar el mundo en conjunto tenemos que
pensar cómo renovamos como red
transformamos lo que hemos construido
para bien o mal en este momento
el último momento el último pilar de la
educación para la utopía puede sonar
extraño pero debemos educarnos para la
inutilidad
concebimos la educación como un arma lo
hemos hablado hoy que debe servir para
algo los gobiernos las agencias plantean
que de ser para la productividad que es
el viraje en el empleo para que el pib
crezca en los países yo digo no es
momento de valorar lo inútil de valorar
esa bella poesía ese baile no va a tener
impacto en el pib probablemente
realmente no tenga mucho que ver con tu
salario pero va a ayudarnos a entender
la experiencia humana acumula
reconfigura moss a cabo valoramos este
caminar que estamos haciendo en conjunto
en la oportunidad de pronto no tengamos
una tercera oportunidad sobre el planeta
en nuestra actualidad
vemos infinidad de cosas tengamos el
televisor accedamos a nuestras redes
sociales veamos lo que ocurre en nuestra
cercanía crímenes corrupción
desesperanza una gran cantidad de
elementos que a veces nos duelen
pensamos lamentablemente todos nosotros
que eso es natural que es acertado que
haya un corrupto que es acertado que una
u otra persona muera a qué tristeza se
están develando los polos y lo
entendemos como si fuera algo normal yo
les digo no no es normal y no podemos
seguir permitiendo esa normalidad
debemos que dar un salto y la la
educación nos da nos brinda las
herramientas para que demos ese salto
porque nos brindamos una oportunidad de
la educación porque no brindamos una
oportunidad a soñar bienvenidos a este
viaje